When Al vegetarian ancestors started eating meat around 2 million years ago,
it wasn't just because animals taste great. It was pure necessity.
Climate change made many of the plants.
Our ancestors relied on less available and meet bridge that gap
from the discovery of fire at the latest meat became a staple of the human
diet. But over the last few years,
eating meat has increasingly been associated with health risks,
like heart disease, certain cancers, and an early death.
So how unhealthy is meat really?
In this video, we'll only talk about meat.
Dairy products deserve a video of their own biologically.
We need to eat for three reasons, for energy to acquire materials,
to fabricate ourselves and to get special molecules that our bodies can't make
themselves the energy.
And most of the materials come from the three macro nutrients, fats,
carbohydrates,
and proteins proteins are the most important resource for repairing and
replenishing. Our cells structures.
The special molecules are a large variety of vitamins and minerals.
We need to drive metabolic processes.
Meat provides us with most of these things.
It contains all essential amino acids, our body needs,
and a lot of minerals like iron zinc and essential vitamins,
some of which are badly found in plants like vitamin B12,
only one essential nutrient is missing.
And most of the meat we consume vitamin C.
It appears in almost all plans and supports our immune system as well as the
development of connective tissues. After a few months,
without it you'd get scurvy,
but meat has another big advantage. It's high bioavailability.
Some of the nutrients in meat are broken down faster and available quicker than
those from plants. Spinach, for example, contains more iron the meat,
but it's absorbed much slower and the body needs more energy to digest it.
Several health benefits have also been observed in communities that rely solely
on meat. The Intuit for example,
are able to survive in extreme climate conditions.
Thanks to eight purely meat-based diet. Since they consume the whole animal,
including the organs, they get every single nutrient they need,
including vitamin C.
So meat itself is definitely not dangerous for us,
but its health effects vary depending on how it's prepared and what animal it
comes from. When talking about meat in the Western world,
we generally mean muscle tissues that have a high nutrient density,
but also lack some of the vitamins that make it possible to survive on meat
alone. The most healthy animals to eat are probably fish.
Fish contains polyunsaturated fatty acids, like a meager three,
which may lower the risk of cardiovascular diseases and support
anti-inflammatory immune functions.
As part of a balanced diet fish can be eaten regularly without worries.
Eating fish comes with its own bag of complications though,
like overfishing and the destruction of the oceans.
We'll talk about that in another video,
a close second is the most popular meat chicken it's regarded as the meat with
the fewest health risks.
The only negative health effect of poultry is a bit controversial.
Fat it's high content of saturated fats is associated with a higher
cholesterol level and cardiovascular disease.
But this idea has also been criticized by a large number of scientists.
Arguing high cholesterol levels might be inherited and not caused nutrition.
So in general, if you won't meet and are concerned about your health,
go for chicken things to get problematic with high intake.
So red meat like beef veal, pork lamb, horse,
and goat, a recently published study recommends for example,
a maximum of 23 grams of red meat per day,
which is a very small steak per week.
However large-scale meta analysis studies have shown that eating 100 grams of
red meat every day increases the risk of diabetes by 19% of
strokes by 11% and of colorectal cancer by 17%.
This sounds alarming, but before we panic,
let's have a look at how these studies were conducted because this brings us to
the second big problem.
When trying to answer the question of whether meat is unhealthy or not most
studies that linked health risks to eating red meat look, case control studies,
which means taking a group of people with a disease and classifying them by
their eating habits, the more red meat they consume,
the more likely they were to contract certain diseases.
The problem is that it's very hard to eliminate other factors.
People who eat less meat tend to live a healthier lifestyle in general,
they tend to eat more vegetables and fruit and are less likely to smoke and
drink alcohol. Most studies try to eliminate these factors,
but it's extremely hard to make definitive statements.
Things get worse. When we look at processed meat though,
processing meat means adding certain chemicals by curing smoking salting or
fermenting, or in other words, making a delicious bacon ham,
salami sausages and hot dogs contain chemicals that are harmful for us
like nitrates and nitrites that can damage the DNA in our digestive system and
lead to cancer.
The who reviewed 800 studies over 20 years and concluded that processed
wheat is strongly linked to an increased risk of colorectal cancer.
Each extra 50 grams of processed meat per day increases your risk of cancer by
18% when it comes to cancer,
risk processed meat is now in the same category as plutonium,
as best dose and smoking the who highlights that it's
research is only about the question of whether or not something causes cancer
and not to what extent,
but processed meat may also significantly increase the chance of suffering from
diabetes strokes and coronary heart diseases.
It also makes a difference what sort of life our meat left when it was still
part of a living being it's common to feed large amounts of antibiotics to
livestock in order to prevent diseases which can spread antibiotic resistance,
combined,
a high consumption of both red and processed meat could increase your chance of
premature death by up to 29%.
This means if your chance of dying is at 3% this year, it's now 4%.
This might not sound like a lot,
but tiny percentages have a huge impact on societies of millions.
They also seem harmless until they affects you to blame me to
loan for bad health would be wrong though.
There is no evidence that the very essence of meat has any negative effects
beyond its high fat content. And even this point is highly contentious,
just like with many other pleasures in life.
Sometimes too much of a good thing is harmful.
Most public health agencies suggest cutting meat consumption to 500 grams a week
while studies suggest cutting down processed meat as much as possible.
So if you feast on meat no more than once or twice a week,
you should be good for most people.
This already means a drastic change in their diets though.
The average American consumes around almost 1,600 grams of meat a week,
the average German, 1,100 grams a week,
and many of us eat much, much more if you're not really sure,
make a small note, whenever you eat meat for a week or two,
you'll be surprised how much it really is.
So most people watching this video would benefit from cutting down on meat,
aside from health concerns.
They're still the fact that the meat industry is one of the largest contributors
to climate change and has reached a scale where it's impossible to deliver
millions of tons of meat and still treat animals with dignity.
We've already discussed that in detail. In another video,
all in all in moderation,
meat is not unhealthy and you don't need to become vegetarian overnight to have
a real impact on your health and the planet,
but your lifestyle choices do matter for yourself and for others.
The key is being open to trying something new once in a while,
maybe you'll discover your new favorite dish until you try.
You'll never know what you'll enjoy or what you're capable of.
Maybe after watching hours of codes cause art videos,
you decided you'd like to learn how to animate. Now you might not know this,
but most of our team actually has a graphic design background.
Learning about design principles. First,
before we got into animation was really key to where we are today.
There's a really great new Skillshare class on using Adobe illustrator,
the software we use to create artwork by graphic designer, Aaron Draplin,
and we can personally recommend it.
It's full of great tips to help understand and simplify a very complicated
program. If you want to do more afterwards,
we have three animation courses of our own on Skillshare to Skillshare
offers over 25,000 classes on topics like film and video editing, writing,
design,
and technology from an array of skilled experts with the premium membership,
you can access all of them for only $10 a month. And as a bonus,
the first 1000 coats cause our viewers to use the link in the description,
we'll get their first two months of Skillshare for free.
[Inaudible].